ab diesen donnerstag erwartet uns eine
buch bestseller verfilmung in den
deutschen kinos und damit geht es jetzt
um michael may holland bekommt die
chance ihres lebens als sie durch ihre
freundin annie ein vorstellungsgespräch
beim circle bekommt der circle ist eine
firma die man sich als kombination aus
google apple und facebook vorstellen
kann
ziel ist es alles zu wissen und den
menschen so gläsern wie möglich zu
machen
nach und nach versinkt er wie immer mehr
im abgeschlossenen arbeitsalltag von
circle ist mit den neuen technischen
möglichkeiten aber glücklich und kann
sogar ihrem kranken vater fundamental
helfen aber dann wird may selbst teil
eines gewagten experiments das sich
nicht nur auf sie auswirkt und man fragt
sich ob wir uns besser verhalten wenn
wir beobachtet werden und ob geheimnisse
immer auch lügen sind dunkel ist die
zukunft gemeinsam werden wir die größten
träume der menschheit verwirklichen
alle krankheiten heilen dem welthunger
risiken
eine gesellschaft ohne verbrechen
erschaffen
für unsere heimat für unsere kinder für
uns alle
[Musik]
werde jetzt teil davon
bis heute geht 110 minuten ist der zwölf
jahren freigegeben und startet hat
diesen donnerstag den siebten mehr 217
in den deutschen kinos mit emma watson
und tom hanks in den hauptrollen
genauso wie aber auch ein jumbo jäger
dabei ist das ist eine buch bestseller
verfilmung und ich möchte voranstellen
dass ich das buch zu der circle nicht
gelesen habe also über den film alleine
sprechen und ihn zweimal im vorfeld
angeschaut habe ein film der bei seiner
inszenierung durchaus schwächen hat und
viel momenten sprunghaft ist das nicht
schafft oder die oberfläche genug katzen
zu können mit gewisse härte durch das
publikum oder anderes publikum heran zu
treten und einen durchschlagenden effekt
zu erzielen aber dennoch auf der anderen
seite grundsätzlich wichtige und auch
philosophische fragen stellt wie gehen
wir um mit unseren technischen
möglichkeiten denn das für eine zukunft
steuern wir was ist wenn es möglich ist
uns alle komplett zu überwachen und
benehmen wir uns dann besser wenn wir
uns beobachtet führen ist es dann im
sinne der gesellschaft sogar beobachtet
zu werden sind geheimnisse immer lügen
ist vieles zu wissen gut aber alles zu
wissen wirklich besser alles thesen die
dieser film aufstellt und vor allem zu
einem ende kommt das glaube ich viele
zuschauer nicht befriedigt aber auf
jeden fall genug raum für diskussionen
lässt soll bedeuten der film selber im
moment schwierig die thematik dahinter
aber eigentlich recht interessant aber
das wird sich auch beim fazit
widerspiegelt rede kurz über den cast
emma watson als mehr holland hat eine
große fangemeinde weltweit ich finde
dass ihre performance in diesem film
weil sie muss die handlung ertragen als
stück weit zu naiv gehalten das ist es
toll mit ihr zu erleben wie sie den
circle entdeckt ihre familie dadurch
beschützen oder ihr auch helfen kann
eine wunderbar technisierte welt in
ihren augen erlebt mittelpunkt einer
bestimmten sache wird über die ich jetzt
nichts bauland will und dass damit jetzt
mitzuerleben das schafft man ganz gut
aber vor allem in bestimmten
wendepunkten wo sie entscheidungen
treffen muss hätte ich mir mehr stärke
mehr härte von ihr gewünschten mehr
erkenntnis die sie auch bekommt aber
umsetzen einer änderung ihrer person die
vielen ihrer persönlichkeit und das
lässt der film leider vermissen und das
ist schwierig für das publikum zu sagen
okay deswegen gehe ich überhaupt nicht
weil das führt dann auch zu sprunghaften
handlungen wenn man der hauptfiguren
nicht mehr folgen kann das macht
inszenatorisch dann das 1
andere problem innerhalb von the circle
dann hätten wir tom hanks und patton
oswalt als ihm in bailey und tom step
die macher die erschaffer die erfinder
die anführer von dem circle während tom
hanks und bisschen in steve jobs mal der
große präsentator ist mit einem großem
charisma seiner starken präsenz ist
patton oswalt er der mann im hintergrund
man schon merkt irgendwas ist vielleicht
nicht ganz richtig mit diesen typen in
der kombination hat man ihnen die
führungsriege aber besonders traum
hengst schaffte es eben aufgrund seiner
gesetzen art und dieser fahren von
jahrzehntelanger der schauspielkunst
einfach immer eine gewisse stimmung zu
erzeugen dass man ihm gerne zuschaut
innerhalb der präsentation von the
circle denken also irgendwie
faszinierend und auch gruselig wie man
eine gewisse ideen verkaufen kann damit
nur noch john wo jeder beweis da aber
aus berlin natürlich euro pacific rim
uprising dann zu sehen im kommenden jahr
hier mittendrin in der circle im trailer
sieht man in ein paar mal aber leider
hat er eigentlich viel zu wenig
screentime weil seine figur ist auf eine
gewisse art und weise mysteriös hat aber
gleichzeitig viel einfluss sehr viel
interessanter hätte sein können sie
stärker einzugehen ich weiß nicht
inwiefern diese figur im buch noch mehr
verwendet wird aber sie wirkt wie ein
bauwerk das in dieser geringen dosierung
für die sie verwendet wird eigentlich
fast nicht mehr nötig gewesen wäre für
den film und ein bisschen das rest
gefühl hatte kemmer brauchte vielleicht
diesen großen namen aus vermarktungs
technischen gründen eher ein bisschen
schwierig da wir sehr viel mehr drin
gewesen lässt man potenzial liegen dass
man hätte mit einflechten können in
diesem film
die kamera arbeitet ist in den vielen
momenten rechtfertig mit frischen farben
eingefangen insgesamt merkt man auch
sowohl bei der kamera arbeit als auch
bei den setting innerhalb von the circle
was das 10 bit angeht immer so ein
technisiert modernes leicht futuristisch
vor allem sehr clean ist klingelt
hintergründe
die haben im grunde auch dieses gefühl
einer gewissen nacktheit schon rein
optisch wenn es darum geht den gläsernen
menschen zu zeigen und die seele vor die
kamera zu führen auch darzustellen das
ist quasi unterbewusstes erzählt finde
ich aber ganz gut so vom stil so diese
screen ist ab jetzt interessant gibt dem
ganzen den futuristischen look und vor
allem wenn viele kommentare im screen
auf ploppen bleibt genug zeit das eine
oder andere
da zu lesen darf man nicht zu sehr
abgelenkt und die musik wirkt ebenfalls
sehr clean alles sehr elektronisch
erzeugte musik sehr ruhige klänge das
passt hätte ich mir ein bisschen mehr
nach gewünscht in manchen momenten
kostüme und make up jetzt nichts was ich
besonders hervorheben würde und dass
auch an effekten sieht ist er soweit
handgemacht bzw der typische
computeranimierte look den man braucht
wenn man irgend genau das als gegenstand
des themas oder als themen gegenstand
innerhalb eines filmes hat ansonsten bei
dieser buchverfilmung die durchaus ein
schwieriges problematisches der nacht wo
ich nicht weiß ob das buch das genauso
hier vorführt ist es am ende ein
filmbeitrag das finde ich gut ich find
die grundidee von der sorge gut ein
thema mit dem wir uns immer mehr
beschäftigen müssen und sollten bei
einer welt die technisch immer weiter
voranschreitet je abstruser das szenario
dieses films eigentlich ist umso mehr
kann man sich wirklich hinter fragen wie
weit sind wir denn schon in zeiten wo
wir diskutieren von city viren
großstädten oder einer zeit wo
deutschland eben auch in einem gewissen
teil während der teilung erfahren musste
was eine gewisse art von überwachung
bedeutet und dass gar kein szenario ist
was so unrealistisch ist wenn wir über
rein über die werte diskutieren ist es
eben ein diskutierter film thesen wie
geheimnisse sind lügen alles zu wissen
es besser oder benehmen wir uns besser
wenn wir beobachtet werden sind auf
jeden fall eckpunkte über die man lange
reden kann und wenn ein film zu einer
solchen diskussion anstößt dann
befürworte ich das grundsätzlich tom
hanks als performance würde ich gerne
nach rausnehmen hat mir immer gut
gefallen und dieses grundsätzliche setup
mit dem circle dessen büro auch wieder
circle und an den infinite loop erinnert
ihn viele elemente zusammenbaut dass man
diese vermischung von realität und
fiktion quasi schon spüren kann sind
alles dinge die ich positiv hervorheben
möchte was eher negativ dass ich finde
dass der viel zu oberflächlich ist das
ein großes problem weil mit mehr härte
und im krasseren fallbeispiel hätte man
stärker noch zum publikum durchdringen
können der film kommt zu einem
schwierigen ende und einer anderen wo
man sagen kann okay was ist das jetzt
zumindest glaube ich dass viele
zuschauer da um befriedet rausgeht und
sich nicht belohnt fühlen wenn sie sich
diesen film bis zum ende anschauen emma
watson ist bedingt nur die richtige wahl
finde ich als hauptdarstellerin ihre
naive art manchmal aufzuspielen passte
seine filme die schöne und das biest gut
rein
the circle hätte ich mir mehr ecken und
mehr kranken gewünscht weil dieser film
lebt nicht diese härte wagte dieser
kombination mit emma watson ist der plot
manchmal etwas unterentwickelt und dann
wieder zu sprunghaft hin und her
merck einen fließenden übergang bei cw
ja auch gewesen den zuschauer so weit
das licht zu führen dass man merkt als
zuschauer ok jetzt ist viel passiert und
wir haben eine große änderung des
grundsatzes und wie weit haben wir uns
schon dahin entwickelt beobachtet zu
werden warum habe ich den übergang nicht
gemerkt der film schafft es das nicht
glücklos und vor allem mit einem
gewissen fließenden ambiente irgendwie
einzuleiten was dazu führt dass es eben
unglaubwürdig wird von der rein
inszenierung so war denn manchmal über
die 110 minuten haben das wirklich zu
einer recht gespaltenen wertung kommen
der letzte film innerhalb der genre
thriller drama science fiction dass
einiges dieser negativpunkte verzeiht
und eben zu diskutieren anregen finde
ich ihn okay
sechs von zehn möglichen punkten an
dieser stelle insgesamt ist es dann doch
rein von der erzählung vom filmischen
herz zu viel schwächelndes gegenüber
allen short anderen filmen da kommt er
bei mir nur auf vier von zehn möglichen
punkten
an dieser stelle was schade ist aber
trotzdem glaube ich dass wenn man fan
des buches ist man gerne mal einen blick
wagen sollte man auch zu schauen und wie
finde ich eine umsetzung alle dass der
vorlage stattgefunden hat und es ist wie
gesagt eine sache zum diskutieren und
ich habe ihn ja auch habe ich eigens
erwähnt im vorfeld zweimal angeschaut
und beim zweiten mal schauen dass es
immer noch interessant weil es viele
kleinigkeiten zu entdecken gibt die über
dem ersten mal zumindest anfallen sind
und vor allem bleibt es immer auch
interessant wie wenn man ein bestimmtes
szenario haben randfiguren auf die man
vielleicht nicht alle im detail achten
kann beim ersten schauen darauf
reagieren haben also war zweiten mal
dann auch noch paar interessante
einblicke gegeben und somit wenn ich am
ende von the circle auf diesem
donnerstag startet in den deutschen
kinos lange nach dem us-start aber eine
riesenlücke witzigerweise drin und ich
danke für ein schatten an dieser stelle
und wünsche euch ganz viel spaß im kino
[Musik]